ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อะไรค่ะนักเรียนมาสวัสดีครับ
นักเรียนเย้
เย้ดีค่ะนักเรียนกลับมาเจอกับพี่อาร์ตี้
แล้วก็ร้องเรียนในช่องช่อง
ให้โอเคครับมาวันนี้เรามาเจอกันอีกแล้วนะ
ครับมาเจอกันวันนี้วันนี้เป็นวันอะไรครับ
วันนี้วันนี้เป็นวันพุธ 5 วันนี้วันพุธ
ครับอ่ากาพี่อาร์ตี้ยังไม่มาก็จะฆ่าอยู่
ไหนอยู่นี่อ้าววันนี้วันพุธโอเควันนี้วัน
พุธวันนี้วันพุธแล้วเมื่อวานวันอะไรครับ
เมื่อวานน่ะเมื่อว่างวันอะไร
เมื่อวานวันอังคารเมื่อวานวันอังคารหรอ OK
คะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับ
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีขอพรุ่งนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีว้าวแค่พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสนะถ้า
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีแล้วออออีกกี่วันจะ
เป็นวันเสาร์ครับ
อีก
3 วันอีก 3 วัน
หนึ่ง
สองสามอ้ออีก 3 วันจะเป็นวันเสาร์อ่าโอเค
แต่วันนี้วันนี้วันนี้วันพุธหน้าวันวัน
พุธที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้วันพุธที่ ๒  ๕
วันพุธที่ 2 โอเคค่ะวันนี้วันพุธที่ 2 นะ
ครับวันพุธที่ 2  a แล้วเดือนนี้เดือนนี้
เดือนอะไรครับอ่าแต่เดือนนี้เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ 5 เรือนกุมภาพันธ์โอเคเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์แล้วปีคศอะไรครับขอ
2522 ค่ะ
2022 เคครับแล้วปีพศ.อะไรครับ
พ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
2565 ครับน้องแค่ปีนี้ปี
2022 นะครับแล้วเองเฮียตี้สังเกตเวทีคิด
ว่าเดือนเนี้ยเดือนกุมภาพันธ์เนี่ยมีวัน
น้อยมีวันน้อยใช่ไหมปกติเดือน
มกราคมมีนาคมสิงหาคมกันยายนจะมีวัน
29  30
31 วัน 11  5 ครับ 8 เดือนนี้เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์จะมี
ปีนี้ปีนี้มี 28 วัน
ใช่ใช้ครับบางวันน้อยปีบางปีจะมี 29 วัน
ใช่มั้ยฮะแต่มีไม่ถึงไม่ถึง 30 ไม่ถึง 31
นะ
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์นะใช่เขา
เดือนที่แล้วครับเดือนที่แล้วเดือนที่
แล้วเดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนที่แล้วเดือนมกราคม 5 เดือนที่แล้ว
เดือนมกราคมเดือนมกราคมมีกี่วันครับ
มี 31 วันหน้าใช่ครับนี่เดือนมกราคมมี 31
วันนักเรียนมองเห็นไหมเฮียตี้ขยายหน้า
เดือนมกราคมมี 31 วันนี้นะครับแต่เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ครับเล่นกุมภาพันธ์มี 28 วัน
ได้มั้ย
ใช่โอเคโอเคโอเคครับหน้าเดือนนี้เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์นะเดือนที่แล้วเดือนมกราคม
เดือนหน้าเดือนอะไรครับเดือนหน้าเดือน
มีนาคม 5 เดือนหน้าเดือนมี.ค.
โอเค of  here ตีเห็นเห็นเดือนมีนาคม
มีนาคมก็มี
31 วันเหมือนกัน
นะไอ้ค่ะเดือนมีนาคมถ้ามี 11 วันหน้า
เดือน
มกราคมก็มี 31 วัน
โอเคครับเราก็อ้าเดี๋ยวเรากลับไปเรียน
ภาษาไทยกันต่อครับอ่าวันนี้เรามาเจอกัน
กี่โมงก็ต้องครับกี่โมงตอนเที่ยงชูนาฬิกา
ตอนนี้
8:00 น
2556 คู่
55s เฮ็ดดีเขียนแบบนี้ไม่ได้ต้องเขียน
เลขอะไรครับเขียนเลข 8 ต้องเขียนเลข 8
ใช่ไหมอ่ะเล็ก 8  20:00 น 20:00 น
55 หน้า 08:00 นเป็นเวลากลางคืนใช่ไหม
ครับอ่ะสองเที่ยงพระอาทิตย์ส่งไม่มีพระ
อาทิตย์ ami พระจันทร์นะครับหน้ามีดาว
โอเคอะตอนกลางคืน 20:00 น 55 นใช่ค่ะโอเค
ครับเดี๋ยววันนี้เทียบพี่กับเรียมจะมาคุย
กันเรื่องอะไรค่ะอาอ้าวันนี้จะมาคุยกัน
เรื่องอะไรอาจจะวันนี้เราจะเรียนจากรูป
ภาพค่ะวันนี้เราจะเรียนจากรูปภาพกันนะ
ครับหน้าเดี๋ยวพี่จะเปิดรูปภาพให้นัก
เรียนดูนะเปิดรูปภาพให้น้องเรียมดูแล้ว
เรียนเกี่ยวกับรูปภาพกันครับนี้ค่ะรูปที่
1 ครับรูปแลหน้าไปดูกันน้านี่ครับในรูป
นี้จะในรูปนี้น้องเรียมเห็ดอะไรบ้างแล้ว
เดี๋ยวรูปดิ
เตรียมเห็น
ผู้ชาย 1 คน 5 ผู้ชาย 1 คนผู้
ชายนี่คนนี้เป็นผู้ชายใช่ไหม
ผู้ชายคนนี้กำลังกำลังมองใช่ไหมลองแล้วก็
กอดอกอาหารใจครับกอดออกอามอเก
มอง 5 ขับ
แล้วผู้หญิงคนนี้ล่ะครับผู้หญิงคนนี้ผู้
หญิงคนนี้เป็นเป็นใครครับ
โรงเรียนคิดว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้เป็นใคร
เรียนคิดว่าเป็นพนักงาน
เป็นพนักงานใช่ไหมครับพนักงานเสิร์ฟใช่
ไหมพนักงานเสิร์ฟอาหารหน้าตาตอนนี้ตอนนี้
วันนี้เขายังไม่ได้เสิร์ฟใช่ไหมยังไม่ได้
เสริมเนี่ยเขารับออเดอร์ขอต้อนรับออเดอร์
รับออเดอร์โอเครับออเดอร์ก็คือใช้ปากกา
จด
ออเดอร์ใช่ไหมครับฮ่าๆๆออเดอร์แล้วเขาพูด
ว่าอะไรครับเขาพูดว่าอะไรน้องเรียนคิดว่า
เขา
เรียกคิดว่าเขาพูดหรือว่า
รับอะไรดีคะอ้ารับอะไรดีคะอ่าหมายถึง
Order  Order ที่ผู้ชายคนนี้จะสั่งหน้า
รับอะไรดีคะหมายถึงอาจะกินอะไรกินอะไรน่ะ
ใจกับจะกินอะไรดีคะแต่คนยังไงถามหินเรียง
ถามที่ Arty ครับเอ่อรับอะไรดีคะก็เหมือน
กับเตรียมถามว่าที่นี่กินอะไรคะอ้า
ใหญ่ครับหน้าเหมือนกันไปค่ะ
[เพลง]
อาๆเฮียตีเป็นผู้ชายกว่านี้เพื่อตีก็จะ
ตอบว่าเออ
อา
ขอเข้าผัด 1 จาน
มองหน้าขอเข้าผัดหนึ่งจากพี่อยากกินอยาก
กินข้าวผัด
ถ้าเขาว่างหนังพลังงานก็จะใช้ปากกาจดอาจ
ตายจดออเดอร์อ้าวผัดข้าวผัดโอเค
แล้วก็มีเตรียมเห็นผู้หญิง 5 มีผู้หญิง
อยู่ด้วยคนนึงอ่ะที่มาด้วยกันใช่ไหมมา
ด้วยกันตายกว่านี้นะอ่าผู้หญิงคนนี้กำลัง
กำลังถือถือเมนูอยู่
ใช่ค่ะค่ะเมนูมีมีรายการอาหารอยู่ในเมนู
อ่าใช่ครับ
ก็จะอ่านใช่ไหมคะพี่ๆครับต้องอ่านอาจมี
อะไรมีอะไรที่มีอะไรที่อยากกินมีอะไรที่
อยากกินหน้าก็อ่านเพราะอ่านเจอปุ๊บอันนี้
ชอบอยากกินอาเกาะสั่งออเดอร์ใช่ไหมสั่ง
ออเดอร์ Order ไปครับ
ต้องพูดว่าอะไร
พูดว่าขอ
ตึ๊ดๆๆอาจจะเป็นขอข้าวผัดขอส้มตำขอ
ได้หมดล่ะได้ครับสลัดที่อยู่ในเมนูที่ที่
มีในเมนูชายเขาเออว้าว
มีอ้าโอเคครับสั่งเรียบร้อยแล้วครับ
ฝั่งเรียบร้อยแล้วถ้าสั่งเสร็จแล้วคณะ
พนักงาน
พนักงานก็จะเอา Order  Order ไปในครัวนะ
ครับหน้าตายแล้วก็ไปทำอาหารทำข้าวผัดทำ
ตลาดมีคำที่เราสั่งออเดอร์ที่เราตัดกลับ
มาให้เราอีกครั้งหนึ่งคำหมอทำสลัดใต้เข้า
ไปเข้าผัดใช่ครับ
เยง 5 โอเคค่ะเดี๋ยวเราไปดูภาพต่อไปครับ 5
ภาพต่อไปอ่ะเป็นภาพอะไรอ่ะนะครับภาพนี้
ครับ
ตาดานี่ไงโอเคเห็นอะไรในรูปนี้บ้างครับ
น้องเรียม
เรียมเห็นผู้ชาย 5 ผู้ชายกำลังทำอะไรครับ
ผู้ชาย
กำลังเปิดตู้เปิดใช่ไหมอ่าเปิดตู้เย็น
หน้านี่ตู้เย็นเค
ใช่เปิดตู้เย็นนะนี่คือตู้เย็นเออคนไทย
เรียกที่เรื่องหน้ารถตู้
ตู้แล้วข้างในข้างในเย็นที่ไหนเย็นได้
ครับหนาวอยู่ข้างไหนในตู้น่ะคนหายก็เลย
เรียกตู้เย็นหน้าแสบตู้เย็นตู้เย็นใส่
อะไรบ้างครับ
อะไรก็ไปในตู้เย็น
เรียงใส่ผลไม้
ผลไม้ก็จะมีแอปเปิ้ลผลไม้
ก็สตอเบอรี่
มีต่อไปนี้สู้เย็นโอเคเป็นผลไม้ครับกีวี
kiwi ละม้ายหน้าครับก็ใส่ผลไม้ในตู้เย็น
ไม้ได้นะอ่ะตู้เย็นของพี่แอดตี้พี่ใส่
ผลไม้ใส่พาร์กใส่อ่าปลาใส่หมูด้วยน่าใช่
ครับ
[เพลง]
ว่าไงมีตู้เย็นโอเคหน้าหนูแย้มคลิปว่าคิด
ว่าผู้ชายคนนี้เปิดตู้เย็นออกมาเขาจะพูด
อะไรครับจะพูดอะไรคิดว่าเขาจะพูดว่า
มีอะไรกิน
มีอะไรกินบ้างอันนี้หิวแล้วใช่มั้ยอะไร
บ้างอะไรมีอะไรในตู้เย็นกินบ้างอ๋อ ok  ok
งานเพื่อแต่คิดก็คิดเหมือนกันคิดว่าเขา
ต้องหาอะไรกินแบบเพราะเวลาเที่ยงตี้เปิด
ตู้เห็นเฮียตีก็จะหาหาของกิน
อ๋อ
สายครับให้ค่ะถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงเหมือนเรียม
เป็นผู้หญิงเต็มอาจจะคิดว่าหาของกิน
ก็คือเรียมจะคิดว่าหา
ครีมทาหน้า
ครีมทาหน้าอยู่ในตู้เย็น
ใช่ผู้หญิงเอาครีมทาหน้าใส่ในผู้หญิงขอ
โอเค
เพียงตีนึกว่าในตู้เย็นจะใส่ของกินแต่
ครีมทาหน้ากินไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
ใจค่ะ
ไปไอ้ติมใส่ผลไม้ใส่ผักใส่ใบปลาได้เป็น
ตู้เย็นไก่ไข่ที่ปลาหน้าคอน High
[เพลง]
โอเคมีนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนไหนใส่
ครีมทาหน้าในตู้เย็นบ้างครับเหมือนน้อง
เรียม
คอมเม้นท์บอกพี่ไปที่หน่อยอ้า
เต็มที่เวลาเราว่าคิดว่าในตู้เย็นไม่น่า
มีทีมทาหน้า
เย็นไงคะพี่อาร์ตี้ในตู้เย็นๆมากๆ
เวลาเราเอาครีมทาหน้าออกมาแล้วก็เปิดครับ
แล้วก็ถ่าอ๋อเย็นออกทอง
หาดคาน่าเย็นๆแบบเรียน a  r
k อ้าในตู้เย็นมีของกินใช่ไหมเปิดตู้
เย็นแล้วหาหาของกินหน้า
เคมีอะไรกินบ้างใช่ไหมครับโอเคอ่าเดี๋ยว
เราไปดูภาพต่อไปกันครับต่อไปกันดีกว่านะ
ครับอ่าต่อไปมีอะไรนะครับเนี่ยนะอ่าเมีย
ตีให้ดูอะไรนี่ภาพนี้ครับแค้
ถ้ามีอะไรในรูปนี้บ้างครับ
เลี้ยงเห็น
ผู้หญิง 1 คน 1 คน
ผู้ชาย 1 คนผู้ชายอีกหนึ่งคนครับ
ใช่หญิงจะมัดผมอ๋ออ่าตรงนี้มัดผมใช่ไหม
ใช่ขับวัตถุผม
มัดผม 2 ข้าง
หนึ่ง
สองครับเรียกอะไรครับถ้ามัดผม 2 ข้างแบบ
นี้เรียกอะไรผมอะไรวัดแกะ
น้องมัทเรื่องแกะเขามาแดก
แกละแหวะแหวะเอ้
ผู้หญิงผมแกะผม Flash เคลื่อยนัก
เรียนคิดว่าเด็กผู้หญิงเหมือนกับค่ะ
เหรียญออกตอนนี้เหมือนแล้วจะได้ว่านัก
เรียนก็มัดผมเหมือนกันนะผม
อะพี่เอาติดใช่
อาหารผู้ชายผมไม่ยาวตัวนี้ก็ผมไม่ยาวมัด
ไม่ได้มัดไม่ได้ไปตีเป็นผู้ชายไม่มัดผม
แกะหน้าเด็กผู้ชายคนนี้ก็ผมไม่ยาวเหมือน
กันผมสั้นสั้นใช้ขับ
เบี้ยที่กำลังสนใจอันนี้ครับสนใจอันนี้
มากกว่า
อันนี้คนไทยเรียกอะไรครับ
คนไทยเรียก
ไอศครีมเรียกสั้นๆ
ไอติมใต้อาเราเรียกไอติมไอติมออกมาจาก
Pretty คิดว่าไอติมก็มาจากไอศครีมแต่คน
ไทยพูดไม่ชัดพูดด้วยอ่าแบบคนไทยอ่ะพูด
ด้วยสำเนียงคนในเรียกไอติมซื้อไอติม
ติมสายครับ
ปิดว่าเป็น
ไอติมรถวันนี้ลาไทยกับเปียปีก็คิดว่าอัน
นี้อันนี้เป็นรสวนิลา
แล้วอันนี้เป็นรถอะไรครับ
เรียงคิดว่าเป็นไอติมรสตอร์เบอร์รี่รส
สตอเบอรี่โอเคโรงเรียนมชอบชอบรสวนิลา
หรือชอบรสสตอเบอรี่ครับ
ชอบอันไหนมากกว่ากัน
วะชอบ
ไอติม
แต่ไอติมรสวนิลา
มากกว่าอ๋ออ๋ออ๋อชอบไอติมรถไฟมิรามากกว่า
มากกว่าสตอเบอรี่อ้าใช่ครับแรงว่าชอบส่อ
berry
น้อยกว่าวันนี้ล่ะ
ใครเรา
ตั้งแต่ที่ชอบชอบมากๆทำชอบไอติมรส
ช็อกโกแลตอ๋อก็ชอบไอติมรสช็อกโกแลตใช่ไหม
ครับอ่าเบียร์ตี้ The นะไม่มีสีน้ำตาล
เนี่ยที่จะระบายให้เป็นสีน้ำตาลเล็กเล็ก
อะไร
นะโอเคอ่าชอบไอติมรสช็อกโกแลตแล้วนะน้อง
เรียมคิดว่าคิดว่าครับคิดว่าเด็กผู้หญิง
คนนี้พูดว่าอะไรครับ
พูดพูดว่าอะไร
เตรียมคิดว่าผู้หญิงพูดว่าเอา
แค่ไหนอ๋อเอาอันไหนใช่ไหมอันไหนอันนี้
หรืออันนี้นะเอาอันไหนน้าๆครับหน้าเพื่อ
ตีเห็นเด็กผู้ชายก็กำลังกำลังคิดคิดว่า
คิดว่าจะเอาอันไหน
หา
โอเคแล้วถ้าเป็น Theater ตีตั๋ว
จะต้องเลือกว่าจะเอาอันไหนถ้าเพียบที่ชอบ
ชอบอันไหนพี่ก็จะตอบวะเอาอันนั้นอันที่
ชอบสมุดสมุดเกียติท่อบชอบรถ Sorry เพื่อน
พี่ก็จะตอบเอา
อันสีแดงหรือว่าเอารสสตอเบอรี่ใช่ครับเออ
เรียนก็จะบอกว่านี่ก็น่าใส่ครับนี้ค่ะนี่
ค่ะ
แล้วถ้าแล้วถ้าพี่อาร์ตี้บอกว่าเอาอันนี้
รสวนิลาเขาเรียนทำยังไงเพราะน้องเรียม Top
รถวันนี้ล่ะแต่พี่เอ็ดดี้จะเอารถคันนี้
คือตาเพียงก็จะบอกว่าไม่ให้
มายๆๆๆไม่เพียงก็จะบอกว่าเทียบที่เอารสตอ
เบอร์รี่ไป
โอเค
ก็น่าได้ครับ 5 วันนี้วันเดี๋ยวเราหมด
เวลาแล้วเค้าน้องเรียมว้าวหมดเวลาเร็วจัง
หมดเวลาอีกแล้วนะครับเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเราทำ
มาเจอกันใหม่นะครับในช่องคอมเพลนสเบอร์
ไทยนะครับกับน้องเรียนแล้วกับเปียตีกัน
ใหม่นะครับขอแค่นั้นงั้นวันนี้ค่ะวันนี้
เราสองคนครับเราสองคนสองคนต้องลาไปก่อน
แล้วครับลาไปก่อนค่ะสวัสดีครับ
สวัสดีครับน้องเรียมไปบายสวัสดีค่ะเพียบ
ที่มี